yeah I got a [ __ ] here looking for
another shot
eight seconds level
they've tied at 1 16 they're gonna leave
you something
and in the last two minutes officials
can stop the game to review are they
going to review if buddies shot was a
dream it sort of stopped the Rockets
fast great VJ had impounded the ball to
James
and the Rockets had not called timeout
[Music]
that took a pic abandoned in the Rockets
had 8 seconds on the clock they were
going to run it in to hearten to get it
up the court that's plenty of time for
him to create something and that just
stopped it cold
his buddy hield put behind the
three-point line yeah looks like it is
that will count for three we'll see how
much time is on the clock when it goes
through eight point four outlets that's
what I felt out again gotta hurry it up
the court
[Applause]
to the basket
[Applause]
Westbrook has had so much success on the
feet here tonight seven four nine in the
beat and that was a very great wager on
up there by Mike D'Antoni using harden
as a decoy and Westbrook just going
downhill in the open court turning on
the Jets
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
later
[Applause]
he beat Dallas with 30 points last night
and tonight he has the game whether
against Houston
[Applause]
goodness nemanja
[Applause]
the Alisa
beat star rockets
[Music]
a stunning three-point shot from Beal
itza who comes out and shoots him from
about 40 feet and shot that from Serbia
and drains it with one second on the
clock
got it off to get to the same winners
for Beal